up giving us all a fun
fine dining experience at the
cosmopolitan but honestly i i really
think fun is an understatement and i
think these two would agree with me
let's welcome maro via lobos the feagle
world's bar manager and gracie pakton
super freako's general manager hey you
guys i feel underdressed
i did not wear my sequins and my
patterns oh you look amazing oh you guys
look so much fun okay so let's start
explaining why i think fun is an
understatement when i when i speak of
super freak take us on a trip to super
frico right now
where i mean we're the ultimate
beel and all i mean tastel house party
wow
where we break down the walls between a
fine dining and anything goes i mean
it's just a crazy experience i don't
think that anywhere in vegas you could
see what we offer oh we're playing some
psychedelic music to set the mood so
when someone walks in
what do they see paint the picture so
you walk into this room that's extremely
bright and you have what is it eight
separate doors that you don't know where
you're going uh and then out of nowhere
the door opens and you're transported
into this purple
hallway then you enter into the into the
departure lounge
uh and then that's where your experience
begins far out and you don't know where
it's gonna happen after that and we
don't wanna tell you because you have to
come and experience it for yourself so
oh my gosh okay so let's move over now
to our drinks because obviously so much
creativity goes into the menu and into
the cocktail so let's start with the
cocktails then we'll talk about the food
oh yeah
yeah absolutely uh so first things first
we are actually going to start with our
best-selling cocktails
it's my favorite
it's called the here comes the sun it's
basically
the beetles right yeah it's basically a
variation
of a margarita where we take aperol
and then we infuse it with these thai
chilies
a little bit of tequila some cherry
herring which is a cherry liqueur i have
some fresh lemon juice orja which is an
almond-based syrup okay bacon house and
some pineapple juice okay well while you
make it while you make it let's talk
about the other cocktails on the menu
because i'm i'm thinking that everything
has a theme right every time
uh so everything is kind of based on the
same concept being psychedelic and fun
and kind of breaking the barrier of you
know the normal normalcy of
you know fine dining restaurants right
right of course and that is just classic
las vegas too so while we finish the
cocktail gracie tell us about the food
well we
think of the ultimate party where do you
get it get it
you think of pizza right yeah we have
the most amazing pizzas and
uh if you didn't know what uh frico
meant frico is the crusty cheese that
forms around like the edge of the pizza
oh so that's what we offer we offer like
the super frico pizza i love that again
we have the amazing pizzas but at the
same time if you want to come in for our
fresh you know homemade pastas we also
offer that we also offer
uh a tomahawk steak so we cater to every
single taste whether you want to have
the fine dining experience or you want
to have the ultimate pizza party i love
that and then next door
oh
next door is a whole other party okay if
you haven't seen opium
just letting you know all right where's
the drink come on i want to taste it
before we wrap
gracie tell everybody how they can make
reservations with you guys so if they
want to go to seven rooms uh they can
make reservations uh seven rooms
otherwise our spiegelworld uh
uh website you're more than welcome to
go that route thank you guys so much jc
i'm gonna send it over to you i'm gonna
keep drinking send me